what's the coolest trick you can do with
it early like what's the coolest isn't
that drawing it and then like doing a
horizontal spin as you draw it like that
acting like that Sam why don't you
ensure the video yeah well you were
enjoying it but okay alright thanks okay
so uh why actin this is going to be our
biggest one of the year so far you have
about twenty people deep here mixed with
casting crew cast is about ten of us and
then another ten floating around doing
different production things we have
hairstyles Department we have a wardrobe
department this time talent just gets to
be talent and not where so when you have
this one so we do have a brand backing
us and they have given us a budget to
make this piece for them to promote the
product so we use that budget to really
pull the resources and make sure we have
everything we need and everything goes
smoothly because we want to get it done
right when you're working for the client
Sam's uh getting our main actors in our
first bit blocking out all the moves so
once they nail this we'll do the camera
I feel like you wish you were always a
blonde because I was a blonde and I was
12 Jimmy Neutron D yeah yeah hey so I
guess part of the process of having a
would come on you got to put on this
head condom on first mm-hmm also known
as wig cap it helps to keep the wig
secure and it keeps the head nice and
cool and comfortable underneath the wig
it's really hard to get like perfectly
fitting armor yeah usually you have to
have a custom-made perfectly fit
I am Ellery she's next to you did I
actually really feel ready for combat
come at me wind the wind is my club fine
it's fine
do we bring that stapler
there was a post on the subreddit the
other day that showed Sam spinning a
revolver in one of our videos and we
thought why don't we tell you guys how
to spin a revolver we've done it a lot
in videos and we want to see who's best
really what's the coolest trick you can
do with it early like what's the coolest
spin this is the trick it's drawing it
and then like doing a horizontal spin as
you draw it like that revolvers spinning
it's kind of the latest thing in these
parts
everyone's I've been hearing hey spin
some revolvers around like hey yo check
out our subreddit slash corridor our
subreddit arc-flash
subreddit the first rule revolver
spinning is you need to start with your
hand gripping to handle and have to end
with your hand gripping the handle like
just simply going like this doesn't
count like it has to eventually come to
a very clean stop in the palm of your
hand unlike that unlike that that's not
clean forward spinning it's a the
easiest because there's the most amount
of weight revolvers are generally I'd
say brunt heavy you want to go forward
you just kind of give it a little bit of
a flick like that and it goes reverse
spinning can work but kind of hard to
get that momentum you know you can't
have to work it a little bit more to get
it to spin backwards
oh absolutely
you go guys I hope you saved up your
allowance for something very very
special because by popular demand we've
taken the theater 42 design and turned
it into one of the coolest shirts you're
ever going to see on the corridor store
if you want a cool t-shirt with a PETA
42 design on it check out the store
right now it's a limited release
available for 10 days only so if you
want this one-of-a-kind design go check
it out right now it's gonna be standing
here shooting at stuff just and a little
more towards the center now and we're
going to just do like north east south
west just firing I'm holding the green
screen because in the green screen
footage the more shadows and the more
wrinkles there are the more difficult
it's going to be for red and team to go
in and
make these elements as a youthful
elements out how to pull out as many
wrinkles as you cans we have the
cleanest plate possible did you not
recognize me no not the gray here I'm
eating nuts
[Music]
this is nuts dude
sucker the millet or it's like real it's
like an actual metal sword this is a
sword this is a sword this is a sword
and the backside there's also more it's
all just ours like this so it's really
hard to hold but it's really easy to
hold like this try picking it up with
one hand out though I got it ready good
how long can you hold it up I don't know
if I did okay this is actually really
similar to a sharp blade inside yeah
you're holding it up Manny now hold it
out oh okay that was that was more than
a man all right what tunity it's real
kind of using your swarm ah
we need Hudson here oh my god you're
kidding me it's actually heavy oh go on
two three four nine six
oh he's holding a champ what are you
what is that good and we find John three
four five six seven eight
nice job on this one then you spin it
yes watch it laughs that's right let's
see
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve fourteen fifteen
sixteen yeah some Akuma giving message
to inky all right Johnny you got some
EMA take you from hat it's mine I'm in
like I think I can handle a sword you
put this frame I'll see ya real oh my
god that's right you brought the sword
in order to determine who is the best
everyone gets one trick take ready go
it's all about that trigger that's all
right
they all pass down to Gorky oh I've been
waiting for when he's going to come out
so fam right now oh my god he broke the
sword we can make it George couldn't
handle me he's you're a brief readout of
the feel the pulse is still there it's
gonna pull oh here we go here we go play
now evil those guys are great and if we
were in the wilderness right now I would
have to do is let's lay down some
burgers right here put some burger it's
racist grill some burgers man what kind
of burgers you're making I'm making some
turkey burgers so nipple surgery I got
some I got some Angus beef on here - I
got can you put can you pour some butter
in here who is this we're big uns we're
vegan is we're in LA we use it out to
the field we are getting set up for the
next shot everybody has suited up in
wardrobe
get the drone up in there we get the
right tape we get the right take again
in triple speed and we run over to get
our green screen element move on to the
next shot here's the breakdown of all
the levels of revolver spinning level 1
level 2 level 3 backwards level 4
backwards into grip level 5 forward stop
backwards into grip level 6 is where
things get complicated sideways level 7
sideways backwards level 8 forward
backwards level 9 forwards backwards and
into grip level 10 is all of them
combined forwards backwards backwards
forwards and backwards into grip doing
this okay what's level 1 all imitating
it get us a couple I want to throw my
bail sure no problem
three that I'm really excited today is
because our primary camera today is the
Phantom 4 Pro in my opinion this is the
best drone you can get right now for a
couple of reasons first off the camera
is 4k that's really nice but what's even
better is that it shoots in a super
super high bitrate it treats a hundred
megabits per second to put that into
perspective most DSLRs shoot around like
40 to 60 resolution and bitrate are
completely independent each other but
the difference is that motion is what
really suffers when you have a low bit
rate so that high bitrate basically
gives you some crisp and clear footage
and then there's also a whole bunch of
sensors it's got like collision
detection on the front and back but we
never crash these things so you're most
of us we are never crashes I take that
back I crash my racing drone I crush up
drones big and small every drone I touch
I crash it so big we've got you crash
that mega drone don't put that and yeah
you guys go back a little further
come this way tour along our axis let's
bring it in a little bit we've all seen
Lord of the Rings we all know what this
is supposed to look like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to and to all right oh my god
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
y'all are aliens dude me that's [ __ ]
up
[Music]